how's it going bros i'm here with the
not beautiful
ken excuse me excuse me
yeah you heard me now we're even for
nothing
dang okay i'm happy to be here you're
beautiful
on the inside thank you thank you wait
i'll take it have you noticed when
someone comments a compliment someone
that it's not pretty and they always say
like you have such
funny character or you're you you are so
lovely
but they never say like they look good
i don't know this is funny you are
beautiful all the way i don't know if i
believe you now at this point
i'm getting a lot of mixed signals here
it doesn't matter
because we're reacting to seven
strangers decides who wins a thousand
dollars
oh my god so they apparently they have a
ton of these like millennials students
and i was like which one do i pick next
it would make sense to pick like
millennials right so i click on it
all right fair dislike ratio and then i
was like i wonder what the other ones
have like it's a really shitty one
and then i clicked on strangers and oh
boy
this is a gold mine this is this is the
[ __ ] i want to see
there's to be something you see in this
video
i have no idea and i'm very very excited
to find out what seven strangers
will do when they decide to win i i
assume the wrong person gets the money
or some [ __ ] but
it remains to be seen why don't we start
watching
welcome to murder dome
no i'm kidding that's not the name
[Music]
did you see the dude the blue shirt
that's right clapping he's like yay
[Applause]
[Music]
do you think he heard what he said
like why am i here all right instant
favorite
honestly none of them pick a favorite
here
we got to know we got to hear what their
stories are you know okay
[Music]
do you guys know why oh look they're
already best friends wow
oh my gosh we're on camera we're going
to win a thousand dollars
uh bubbies they don't know what yeah
they're strangers so they don't know
each other why are they hugging
huh stop that i just say like it's weird
how people that meet for the first time
are like super overly friendly like oh
yeah we just met we're gonna do a theme
together but then like you get to know
them for 10 minutes later and you're
like
i need you get away yeah every reality
tv show ever
right exactly yeah one thing i noticed
in every single
reality tv show i have ever watched
there's always that one person that says
i'm not here to make friends i'm here to
win and they never
they never win because because everyone
hates them
i've never seen that person win but they
always say it it's so funny
they even do like the dramatic zoom in
when they say they look in the camera
i'm here to win
yeah i hate them all already i don't
know why they're so extroverted i can't
relate no
i can't because there was money involved
no i'm sorry
i just want y'all to make the ones reign
so i can dance i don't know you can't
put a
i said they knew about that thousand why
were they say they
faked their reactions for the murder
dome
who would fake reactions that's [ __ ]
cringe dude
there's seven of you here you have to
decide who leaves with a thousand
dollars
that's the individual you guys have to
decide together who's the one person
guys here's the thing we could each
leave with like 150
yes girl yes queen
someone gets it 140 bucks actually to be
precise but yeah
hey quick maps i checked the last
episode because i wanted to know
oh oh yeah yeah that's fair right
i mean yeah but where would where would
the drama be there's got to be
you know they said they're there for the
money why it's not my problem if they
get a [ __ ] episode right
yeah yeah right okay guys we'll all just
split it but then the producer's like
no uh actually yeah they probably done
that right
yeah i'm sure someone's tried to do that
like no that's not why you're here yeah
guys that was great but like can we do a
part where you pick one as well they
probably do that yeah
yeah we're all we're on to you the cut
give it a whole bag
here are the rules we are going to break
it down by rounds the first four you
have to decide
which person gets voted off okay
and then for the final three people you
have to unanimously decide
who's the one person who leaves with it
so you can't split it then
you have to vote someone up that's the
rules okay
fire so what's everybody's sign what
does that have to do with anything i
want to know bank balances
i want to know yes all right she's on i
like that
bank balance no how much money you got
what are your
star sign shut up [ __ ] that don't waste
my goddamn time with a buffoonery
star sign what are you gonna do then
yeah
i'm a virgo oh you will you mentioned
exactly so i'm black in america so [ __ ]
sucks
that's why i deserve a thousand dollars
i'm an immigrant
immigrant card got shut down real fast
what if we donate the money i know who
needs to go because you said
to charity so he's number one
i think you gotta go wait what he has to
go because he said he wants to give it
to charity
yeah okay why all right
so we got some we've got some
interesting people here some good
strangers
i'm sorry starting to understand the
dislike ratio in this video a bit
sort of slowly makes sense so this guy
wants to give money to [ __ ]
charity get him out of here
i think they took the lesson from our
our last video where we talked about who
like whoever talks the loudest becomes
the leader because they're all just
yelling at each other right now
oh they watched our video or didn't they
they're like oh yeah
smart i'm sorry i mean i was kidding
okay were you yo but you wouldn't say
donate to charities if you were really
kidding
if you're really broke right give me
your pitch give me your 30 second pitch
why you deserve it
oh okay so you can only donate to
charity if you're broke that was their
argument
no that he has money that he doesn't
need that's why he's gonna do it to
charity
so he's got money yeah right oh my god
um you are especially vocal
what do you got i spend every single day
also how are they already like acting
more immature than the [ __ ] high
schoolers
all right yeah yeah this is embarrassing
trying to save the world i work on
issues of climate change i am a good
person
and i need new tires
is that better than charity what
she needs to charity man she needs new
tires
that's like the biggest scam of all time
i only got new tires one time and this
guy was such a salesman he was like i
was like so like will there be a
difference now he's like yeah
like you know when you have new shoes
it's just like that i drove it couldn't
tell it goddamn
thing different sent me back 300 bucks
don't even go into dad mode over here
you saying that you've only changed your
tires one time
ever okay
i am tired what do you mean how often do
i change my tires
wait wait what do you drop them until
they're bald the wire's hanging out what
do you mean
i don't drive that much i'm not american
claire oh my gosh
what do we want to do for winter time
drive winter tires so you
but i get someone to do it for me and i
probably could figure it out i just
don't care enough
i know how to do it with an oil test you
pull the thing down
oh everything's fun
[Laughter]
and then i don't know what that means
but maybe i need more oil or not
listen i would do it i would do it but
the thing is
they always do it for me i'm like dang
it i wanted to i wanted to do that
took it away from me again all right
so tires yeah well what what what
what well you know they have they have a
mileage limit right where you're
supposed to change them out
so like it can protect you from sliding
off the road when it rains and things
like that
flipping volvo the safest car on the
planet
all right that's some weird ass american
off-brand
i get it change your tires because you
just buy a whole new car
i had my same car shut up all right i'm
done
i've spent over 3 200 in rent this month
alone
um plus moving costs right your rent
ain't my problem
what the [ __ ] do you hear like
whispering behind her back while she's
telling her like oh my god
did she really today i've spent over
thirty two hundred dollars in rent this
year yeah they are
oh she's like pointing at her like this
[ __ ]
rent huh she moved all day
doubt yeah seeing lifting [ __ ] i can
tell that plus moving costs
bribing people to help me liar no
okay okay here we go i haven't been
working since april this would be my
third surgery
within a year since my my initial
accident like seriously my bank account
is literally like negative 300 right now
if you're going paycheck to paycheck
where those paychecks coming from if
you're not working hold on hold up
if you got hurt at work where are you
working i like how they're instantly
trying to like
find holes in her story which is fair
actually
she's been so vocal this whole time now
she's stuttering when she's trying to
tell her story i don't
already don't believe her now i already
don't like her so it doesn't matter what
she says
her name's shakira there's only one true
shakira okay yeah yeah
yeah she's a phone and you know it
that's my paycheck to paycheck but you
only get how much of your income
you only get 16 of your exactly april
it's now how you getting workers comp
for
six seven months like y'all asking too
much questions but that is the truth
i am 19. what
dude was like how you still getting
money
i'm 19 years old i'm a full-time student
money would really freaking help i just
bailed out my parents 10 grand and that
was actually what i was supposed to use
for my daughter's college fund
sorry what if we helped you by
connecting you to a mentor that we know
yeah i know some people i mean wow
they're trying to bargain with her
that is interesting yeah we can tell you
need the money but like we can help you
up
other ways so that someone else can get
this money like we have a mentor
a mentor ain't worth [ __ ] anyone that
has a mentor is a dumbass
the true what is it yeah that is hundred
percent who has a mentor
i don't know the concept's new to me
wait you never heard of a mentor
and like a teacher like someone's going
to be like this is how you
no people pick pick a mentor in their
business to like help them through their
like
decisions of like what path they want to
go down to and like
strategic choices in life and stuff like
that
like i'm an adult caretaker of you or
some [ __ ]
like obviously it can't be her parents
because she just had to build them at
ten thousand dollars
jesus she needs a mentor actually damn
for a day but you teach a man to make a
thousand dollars
but i will still have the thousand
dollars thank you very much
they're so annoying they just sat there
on the couch how broke they are and
they're talking about how this mentor is
going to
make this girl money like yeah don't you
all want the mentor then
what why are you so broke then if you
have these men
what oh god they are so great i love it
so my bills are my husband was able to
pay them but they're coming up again and
we may end up homeless
how long have you haven't you had a job
since september
we're in october yeah my brother's
getting married in michigan
this is already a no you want the
thousand dollars to go to michigan
i mean that's yeah sure michigan can you
just drive anywhere in america
yeah i mean you can yeah sure yeah but
you're flying with your cars
with your fancy cars then we need to get
tires
i could not stand being in this audience
i love this group like
i wouldn't even know how to interact
with this i'm so glad i'm just judging
them from the outside
okay that's all i have to say my only
case that i can make is
is that you know i work hard i would use
the money to you know
fix my car because it's had i've had a
busted windshield and a busted
bumper for a while but it's still
operable right yeah for sure totally all
right
okay okay nobody's bullying him because
it moved me when i said
how will you decide who goes off we
should write something down put it in a
pot and then maybe one of somebody else
can read it like i'll read it i'm her
her name is my name is your name too
i didn't realize how annoying this would
be the watch yeah
like i understand the dislike ratio now
they're all so mean to each other it's
like
none of them had a really good reason so
far i like they
they all have their reasons but like
everyone's response is well just do this
you know right yeah you don't need a
thousand dollars just yeah yes
just facetime oh you need to fix your
car
just walk bruh have you heard of legs
you got some legs there yeah oh you can
play your ring
just move
just live up the trees the berries and
the bees
come on okay you guys have two minutes
sorry joe you got to go sorry joe well
done
really car with tires
there's where you'll sit okay yeah cool
god they are so much meaner than the
high schoolers
and i like how they they're like oh no
joe sorry to see you go
even though we were like sorry joe
come on sorry your reason stop the dance
joe
[Applause]
you're playing into it what are you
talking about you guys ready for the
second round
yeah yes all right we've started oh do
you think
abby you should go next because
using the money for a plane ticket joey
having a good time
i feel bad you can take the greyhound
i'm trying
you could amtrak you could drive you
could drive yes
at this juncture i'm so sorry abby but i
have to agree
i gotta pay for plane tickets too
and i just no one is making a case for
themselves they've just decided abby
needs to get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah they're all just ganging up on one
person at this point god damn
i i just have to pay for one too and i
could barely yeah okay just pay my rent
yeah yeah we're about four minutes in
guys my priority is finding a house and
you're just getting some tires i need to
pay
wait didn't joe wilson want to donate to
charity as well wasn't that his thing
oh so yeah yeah they said he also had a
busted car with like a broken window
and they wanted to put him out because
he had money right clearly
yeah oh my god i know i'm going next so
i just want to say something
why do you think that he was you're
going next the [ __ ] could be going
because everybody stood up and said abby
i think you should go next yeah
i think it's safe to say she's going why
you going next girl not like we all just
said you're going next
like oh shoot like maybe i don't deserve
this you know i'm like
[ __ ] were you forfeiting no i'm not
forfeiting
we're of the same spirit right now me
and this girl like i wouldn't want to be
on this couch either with these people
jesus christ
get me out oh my god please i would pay
a thousand bucks
not to be part of this holy [ __ ]
everyone who thinks i should go home
please raise your hand
okay that's done now everyone
anyone who thinks that abby should go
home raise your hand anybody thinks i
let you go home please raise your hand
girl you should never say i don't
deserve something
made it i don't know how the [ __ ] she
recovered from that
oh that's what she said i guess she
they're mocking they're mocking her now
i mean we laughed too
because she said she's not going out but
like yeah but we're laughing about it
like good fun you know they're just like
literally
yeah at this point oh my god don't give
me these people how do these people
honestly i'm at that point where i'm
starting to think whoever does get the
money does not deserve it
crazy as abby was on the chopping block
she was like
i know i'm next oh you do okay then
you're next but then you got up there
and you just and you started crying and
you were like i don't even know if i
deserve this
okay well never mind abby you next yeah
yeah yeah look at joe
look at that joe he's so done dude i
think
everybody here has realized that
everybody hears a piece of trash
[ __ ] hell everybody just wants to get
out of here at this point
they are so horrible my god
like whatever reason they have for the
money it's just like i would not give a
sh
because their personality is so awful
right man you got me cut through
you cried you're done you said maybe you
don't want to be here you're done
yeah you had one thing that none of us
do when i was a child
you could have played that baby car my
baby ain't got no diapers
my baby ain't got no wise i'm out of
breath
i want to work dogs she should have
oh my god they got so much advice
they're they're telling her how she
should have like made her case
because that's what they would have done
which makes this whole thing seem so
phony as well
they catch a sociopath right here yeah
right
they're just like [ __ ] dumb but you
use the crying card at this level of the
game
what are you [ __ ] [ __ ] huh you
should have talked about me
being a mother that's what she had to
get what she needed it's a player's club
line
ronnie hello quote you live buy it you
get it but you gotta
to get what you want hey chris is that
how you're playing this kid no i'm not a
baby
you don't have a baby do you guys think
the most sympathetic people are the most
vulnerable in this game
yes because they're gonna fall for a
soft story sob story
yeah stop story if you needed the money
for yourself all four of the shoes he'll
be on this cat but she
no but she's like she almost fell for it
she fell for the one abby gay but only
messed her up this man with a [ __ ]
ralph lauren
and khaki jeans like an apple watch
what the [ __ ] is happening
in this video she felt so hard that she
didn't think she deserved it sorry i was
listening
to you guys i didn't vote for you girl
you guys i want to remind you the final
round is when we get down to three
people yeah and all those three people
have to she's leaving
yeah good girl get the [ __ ] out of there
nobody gets the money
cut will not be keeping that thousand
dollars trust me
you guys ready for the next round i'm so
glad she left because
these guys yeah yeah i would not sit
there
and take that [ __ ] i wanna
i hate them i hate them so much
they're such bullies how do you guys
feel about games of chance
no i don't trust that like rock paper
scissors
no excuse me we got the whole mob
mentality going on right here you want
me to give that up for a game of chance
you're out next girl try to bargain with
us [ __ ] she going she's good definitely
going out
it's it's written in stone like i had a
really hard financial time a couple
months ago and i gave so much plasma
that i passed out on the bed
yeah i have a scar too
a minute ago you didn't know how to get
money to go on a plane
if i have a plasma scar doesn't that
tell you i'm trying to do everything i
possibly can
i mean are you yes
i think she's had enough
wait what's that plasma scar like
donating blood what are they talking
about like
uh yeah like don't like selling your
blood basically like nothing okay
for money wait wait you get money for
that uh you can
in some places how much money we're
talking about
[Music]
i need a new pair of tires clearly
dude you should go hit the [ __ ]
like throwing away
what have i done
the tragedy should go everybody walk up
to it
and it's facing the camera and then
we'll turn around and show the people
who who has the most names on the board
let's do that i'll hold the board so i
think it's a unanimous decision
sorry abby good luck to all of you
sean shocker wow i didn't see that one
coming yeah
if i even put it on the board so like
everybody can see what everyone else is
voting so they feel
peer pressured to vote the same way yeah
yeah yeah or the board thing coming in
people when they're like because i can't
just be like because you gotta go
you're not a person no bruh i'm just
being real right if i hurt my knee and
i'm out of commission i can't be a
bartender i can't be a hairdresser like
i can't do that
and i have [ __ ] nothing so you're
like a dresser hairdressers make a lot
of money girl no but i'm not i'm like
from my job oh she slipped up there huh
yeah they're the top of the cream my
dude
getting those 500 haircuts left and
right you're a [ __ ] hairdresser
what are you some fancy schmancy pants
here
everybody we got a rich
got himself a [ __ ] adventure
god they're trying to take anything to
scrutinize
why don't you take it from three jobs to
one that's like saying why don't you get
a job
i mean i'm in the process of getting a
job i would never work three jobs and be
stressing myself
out like that because that's
unfortunately i got nothing and i'm
doing the [ __ ] best i can
and if i don't get a break there's
there's
there's there's and i was just saying
that like
having a kid is like that's talk about a
guaranteed thing in your future like
that
that's a guaranteed future to me you
have the child
you have sex to have the child and now
the child is here so you have to pay for
your child
and be responsible
is your [ __ ] fault you dumbass
why do you have a child you had a baby
you had a baby
my [ __ ] problem i gotta get i gotta
get another apple why apple watch
[ __ ] oh it's a tie
i think they should do a tie break
amongst themselves like sudden death
wait who's hold on
is that him no it's a girl on the right
how about they decide
sure that is not fair we gotta figure
something out we can take some input i
don't think that they should be able to
vote
i don't think that's going to be fair
because every single one of them before
they got out voted for me
so what are they going to say right now
yeah how do you how do you possibly know
that um i saw you write my name down
wrong
you voted because you wrote the thing
wrong and i'm
you just look like you're assumed about
me you feel bad about me can we can we
can you give us a second can we pause
i'm sorry can we really pause i really
don't need you to antagonize me why
don't you just
be quiet i have to okay oh my
that's antagonizing to you she's the one
that's just throwing him under the bus
and now it's like he's the bad guy
i need you to shut the [ __ ] up over
there
okay do not antagonize me
i need you to be quiet he's like i have
been that's like literally the only
thing i've said the whole time i've been
here
what do you bro props to joe for keeping
it
the end man i'd be fuming man keep going
back to that
she's in charge everybody
see that's uncalled for unnecessary yeah
that was uncalled for
that was uncalled for he called her up
for crying
for like five minutes until she had to
leave like i should have
responded back to that i mean nobody's
over here talking to you you're right
now you're just wasting our time right
that's enough
oh my god
they are so annoying no one's [ __ ]
talking to you
we were just waiting but now we're not
now i'm deciding yeah
this is a great school way of
communicating
how do you not grow out of this i'm
gonna take off two hundred dollars from
the pot
no no and we're gonna kick off one
person randomly you
voted for me and she voted for her so
why don't you guys talk why would you
say that you don't know who voted for
who
i voted for cat yeah i didn't what why
would you say that i thought it was your
handwriting raise your hand if you vote
for cat
[Music]
guess so everybody everything's too
personal
this what's that on y'all get a job
i will do some hair more
so this is the final dude that was his
comeback
wow dude you're unemployed do some hair
more
unanimously decide who's the one person
who
leaves with a thousand dollars or no
one's going home with money
okay all right who do you think is gonna
get it then ken
my guess is the girl on the left the guy
in the in the middle is just mean and
the girl on the right it's
it's already made it far enough okay
i'll get i'll guess girl on the right
then because i feel like she will play
the victim hard enough that she that she
will eventually leave she's got a
problem
yeah all right nobody
[Applause]
everybody on the sidelines who do you
think deserves out of those three
none of them yeah can i like yeah it's
the only
decent sentence i've heard this entire
video
the only true thing probably i'm voting
for myself
i mean yeah but it has to be three of us
are you still voting for shakira yeah
hey he's so mad
i told you bro we decided on shakira
yeah we picked shakira because
they had already decided prior and i
said he's leaving the money on the table
right so i'll give somebody that can
could use it i just hope you're online
i'm not no i'm not so much not you're so
mad about it i i already
know that i'm i'm okay without this if
they all need the money that badly why
don't they just split it
i don't understand that all right let's
let's all vote for you and then we can
split the money three ways how about
that
i mean fair enough if they do that right
if they all need it they're
that bad i mean 300 will do come a long
way thank
god that shit's over yeah it's been an
awful experience
yeah because yeah you all made it
terrible
oh my god not all of them but yeah that
was i i
yeah this doesn't even feel like a
rewarding experience to watch like we
get
like oh she got the money oh crazy like
no
oh my god thank jesus they get their
this is over with
like this video makes me so angry wow
that comment right there
yeah i'm just like really annoyed with
this [ __ ] video i
i thought it would be funny it was just
like trying not to get angry challenge
at this [ __ ]
oh boy dull and dark in the comments
well at least put on didn't win what a
dreadful person
all right dolan dark said it i mean
right there the last three reminds me so
much of bullies at my school
yeah they're very childish calling
people out for random [ __ ] whatever they
could
they they ripped on that girl for crying
so much that they had to like
make cuts i am happy with the decision
because i am an adult because i got the
money [ __ ]
y'all dumb [ __ ] mama person
that's happy
i'm very thankful for the decision that
they made and you know how everything
played out
and now i'm excited i'm happy
oh if a picture picture says a thousand
words it's right there
[Laughter]
i hope they wire that money to her
because they give it to her in cash
she's getting jumped out back at the
studio
are we are we doing like are we can we
are we having a reunion show too
yeah um i'm sick that day
[Music]
old bullies want reunions that's like
the most bully sense i've ever heard
but i gotta relive it right god
damn i am speechless that was the worst
video i've seen in forever thank you
very much for inviting me to this
i can't believe i'm sorry i apologize
if you're angry smash a like on this
video don't understand
thank you ken i would i wish i could say
it's a pleasure being here today but uh
[ __ ] all right
all right bye i guess see you later
again